[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
spring in the hall of famer
two-time nba champ chris bosh
good to talk to you again chris how are
you i'm doing good man good to see you
everything is uh everything is going
well
how's the jumper right now man you know
it is rusty i haven't uh i haven't shot
a jumper in a while
how long did it take you to get used to
your role with the heat
because you were you were uh all-star in
toronto you put up big numbers and then
now you gotta be the third guy yeah
and it's not as easy as it looks i i
didn't get used to it
um probably until we finally won the
first championship and
and then it was always one of those
things where you know i constantly had
to reinvent myself i don't think i
ever all the way got used to it because
um
i had to morph you know and even on some
nights you know it would change so
you know brown or d might be out and i
have to up you know my scoring
um some nights i would just set screens
and
be the big guy rolling down uh the paint
and uh playing defense some days would
just be
you know we need you to guard the
biggest guy and and guard 50 screen and
rolls
and you know that was one of the
fascinating things i found
from being with that team but i would
say in in
you know just getting used to being
uncomfortable it definitely took
more than one season i would say a
season and a half to kind of really fit
into my role and then
even after that i had to get used to
things changing lebron ever really get
mad at you
oh i'm sure i'm sure i mean you know
that's uh
that's one of the parts of uh playing
the game right if you're on a team with
somebody you're gonna
go through the whole wave of emotions
and i'm sure
you know he uh he was upset with me i
for sure was upset with him
on many occasions but we were always
able to
work it out you know work through
communication and and it always came
from a place to get better that that's
what made it important
uh what do you make of what happened
with the celtics here's ange
you know leaving uh brad stevens moving
up
you have a i thought you had a team that
could win
championships plural here with that
young talent
and that you know that window of
opportunity closes pretty quickly
look at what the nets have there in
brooklyn so you're not going to be
better than them you're not better than
the sixers so
yeah uh how would you how would you look
at the celtics right now
well they don't have to rebuild um you
know with tatum and brown
marcus smart they have good young talent
they have a nucleus i think that they
can build off of
i think um definitely this year was a
disappointment i think they'll be the
first
uh to tell you that they definitely
underachieved this year
and then injuries started piling up and
it ended up being a disappointing season
for him but
with the talent that they have they have
to continue i guess you know there were
some things to figure out
obviously right but i think for them
moving forward
they need to put the necessary pieces um
in place in order to be successful
obviously right
but i mean they're right there they have
to continue to get better
um obviously there there's been a huge
shake up
i'm interested to see who who will be
the next hires
um for coaches and gm's and stuff like
that and
filling in the rest of the gaps with the
team your best miami heat team against
this brooklyn nets team
who would win yeah oh you know i'm a
competitor man i always say we're going
to win
every single time but i tell you man
those uh the nets the more they play
together
uh they'll get better and better they're
they're tremendous offensive team
so you gotta you gotta guard duran right
you you get durant
uh i mean we probably move around i
would guard him a little of course or
try to brian would guard him mostly
probably shane battier would guard him
quite a bit but
yeah that would be the fun part when
they go small and how how dynamic the
game would become and how we try to
match up with that
what's the most impressive performance
that you ever witnessed whether it was
on
you know with a teammate or the
opposition uh kobe scoring 81 points oh
um yeah
[Laughter]
i was a young fella in that game taking
my beatings man
[Laughter]
but what's that like though when do you
realize uh oh this is historical
yeah it was surreal i mean um
you re when once you realize that it's
too late and it's it's kobe and
and i remember just kind of running down
the court and i kept looking up at the
screen and it's like
his score was multiplying i was like how
does he scoring five points at a time
like this is crazy
and it was you know we were a bad
defensive team that year and just
you know we were trying to right we're
trying to figure things out and it's
just like oh my god we're in the stable
center they're killing us and
everybody's laughing and cope everybody
except kobe he's just got the eye of the
tiger right now and
he's unstoppable it was it was just an
incredible performance it's one of those
things where you find yourself
watching even though you're in the game
do you think he could have scored 100
yeah yeah he's one of those guys
yeah i was so the funny thing about that
story is like uh
i think um a month before a few weeks
before he has 61 and three quarters on
the mavericks yes
and i was looking at that game i said
what in the world are they doing
how do you let this guy score 60 points
in three quarters
that's atrocious
[Laughter]
got smashed that was crazy man
i feel bad for jaylen rose whenever the
anniversary comes up
everybody wants to talk to jalen because
jalen was guarding well trying to guard
kobe in that game yeah
yeah he got uh he got a nice chunk of
those uh those points man kobe gave it
to everybody
what was the second best performance you
ever witnessed
uh lebron um
game six in boston in 2012.
by far what were his incredible what
were his numbers in that do you remember
uh i can't remember i know we have i
think i want to say 45
yeah i want to say you have 45 points
but i remember
um i had a i had a sore groin and of
course being down 3-2 going into boston
garden
you know it's uh it's not in a situation
you want to be in and i just remember
him
being pretty confident and i was i was
ailing i had a i had a hurt growing so
i'm trying to figure out how i'm just
even going to contribute and so i'm
playing with pain
and about midway through the second
quarter early in the second quarter i
was realizing like man this
this dude hasn't missed yet and so i
just
just got the hell out the way and it
made my job a little easier because i'm
like hey if we get
if we keep getting stops just give the
ball to him and
we'll just continue riding this way but
it was an incredible performance
why do you think paul pierce doesn't
like lebron
i don't think is that that he doesn't
like him i think it's just
you know extreme competitors there's bad
blood though chris
oh yeah of course i mean look you know
playoffs you play
when you play somebody so many times in
the playoffs like they did you're
naturally just not gonna like them
you know you don't have time to go to
dinner or sit down
you know um there's been plenty of
celtics that
i don't like you know and uh that's just
that's just how it goes but paul he's
he's a
you know he's a huge competitor um he
wants to win and if he doesn't
he's probably not in the best mood who
who do you not like to this day
ah oh well you know there's nothing
that's being played over
nothing's bled over you know it's all
good man
probably i'm retired you know so good
okay
all right you're good with kevin garnett
yeah oh that's we were um we were
talking uh at the hall of fame um
after his induction uh we got the chat
and you know i've
we like i said we were extremely
competitive and we would chirp back and
forth but
um that was one of the best parts about
um being outside of the game is having
the conversations
and that's the first thing i said to
kevin i'm like yo you remember you used
to foul me the whole
game they didn't call it you know but we
had a good time talking about those
intense battles it's a lot of fun
kg would get in anybody's face it felt
like
oh man i had to stop talking to him i
stopped talking to him you know during
the game
i got i got involved in talking trash
with him one time and he got the best of
me and i said you know what
that's never gonna happen again i
overextended myself
i'm not a trash talker let me just go
out here and play ball
we're talking to chris bosh who is going
to be inducted into the hall of fame
uh won a couple of titles and uh he's
got a new book out it's called letters
to a young athlete now available online
and wherever books are sold what were
you hoping to accomplish
when you first started this project
you know at first it was just more of a
cathartic experience
um you know just trying to get things
off of my chest and trying to figure out
what i'm gonna do next
uh with my life um you know after losing
the game so quickly
um and not being able to play anymore
because of my medical condition
um you know i kind of had to rebound
pretty quick and
you know in in trying to develop new
habits and
dive into those hobbies that i love and
and really really
dig deep and try to find those things i
was just trying to get things off my
mind
and then it kind of transferred into or
transformed into
you know helping a young athlete the
book is called letters to a young
athlete so i wanted to speak
to all generations of course but have
that universal message to where
you know people can take it um whatever
they want for themselves
look at the lessons that helped me uh
get to this point today
and you know hopefully it'll help them
so that's kind of
how everything transformed i wanted to
leave a momento
if you will uh for both the game of
basketball and the game of life
what kind of risk were you uh
like at at worst you know were you
risking your life
not knowing it when you're out on the
floor um it didn't get to that point
um i was um the first time um
you know there were two conditions that
happened with me two instances
the first time i was and you know i
didn't know it um and then
after after that you know pretty much
when you
get that second blood clot there's
nothing else to talk about you know it's
almost like you're radioactive
so you know playing basketball pretty
much was not
uh in my best interest i was told it was
in my family's best interest and pretty
much
you know a team being um in a situation
where they could be liable
you know they were not going to uh uh
you know deal with those things and i
eventually had to come to that
realization
yeah it's got to be tough because you
want to play but you have to understand
that that team doesn't want you out
there i mean we've seen this happen with
hank gathers reggie
lewis i mean there are there's been
athletes who passed away
right in front of us absolutely and um
even uh the week before
uh i was hospitalized for the first time
jerome kersey passed away
uh from a blood clot um you know from a
pulmonary embolism
and you know that that really i mean you
know when you're
younger right you don't think of those
things you don't think it's gonna happen
to you and then
you know next thing i know i'm in a
doctor's office and they're telling me
all this information that i don't want
to hear and
you know i had to rebound from that but
all in all i was able to kind of um
get back to my normal self with the help
of my family going those
on those quests to find out who i am and
what i want to do with this life
i'll leave you with this uh finish the
sentence if the lakers don't
get out of the first round um
you expect them to make some big
moves in the summertime i think um
you know they've just it's been a rough
go at it this year they've been hampered
by injuries i think
you know we all see that they're not
playing uh like they were last year and
and even for brian i mean he's um you
know he struggled especially i think
that high ankle strength i mean heinkel
spring
took him out of his rhythm i think for
them they'll have to add some more
pieces and
and you know try to compete for a
championship again next year but you
were talking about playing
that game in the garden with a strained
groin
and i mean a.d wasn't able to play but
just how limited are you were you with
an injury like that
it's it's all the way limiting and this
is me um when i when i
i tore my inductor muscle that's pretty
much what it was
and uh it was on mother's day
and it was game one of the second round
i tore i tore it and i didn't come back
until
the the longest i or the shortest i
could rest was three
weeks and it hurt like hell still coming
back
so an 80 situation i don't i really
don't see him being able
uh to come back from that he'll you know
he'll have to rest and he won't play
until next season most likely
he's chris bosh the new book is letters
to a young
athlete can't recommend it enough now
available online wherever books are sold
hope you're doing well chris uh congrats
on everything and uh we appreciate you
joining us
i appreciate you man appreciate your
time all right we'll take a break phone
calls are up next here on the dan
patrick show